it's quiet out here
the desert sprawls from Horizon to
Horizon my purest light it's Twilight
red
there are no edges here no angles just
curves the gentle rise and fall of
Doom's as far as the eye can see
and everywhere beyond that had a visitor
from some other world laid eyes on this
place they might have found it serene
even beautiful pure I can enjoy and no
such delusions regretfully for I know
what lies beneath and among the sands of
the endless desert a charnel-house
spanning an entire planet 7 billion
human souls grown thin and fine until no
trace of their existence could ever be
found I know this because I put them all
there oh brother
it all happened so fast once we're gone
it began the daily you you that I have
never known found my power the power I
hid from myself in some previous life
for reasons I can now easily guess I was
looking out of the window of my
apartment
so I can see the stars and instead I saw
you blazing as you taught yourself
asunder to keep the power away from
yourself he didn't trust what he would
do it and so he chose to throw it away
you knew yourself all too well as I
suspect I did too at one point I all
accounts I should not have been able to
see you for my apartment was a truly
tiny containment cell about half a mile
underground
but such considerations never meant much
to one living entirely in his own world
when I saw the moment of your demise I
became aware of myself for the first
time in I have no idea how long
whichever part of me that led me to
throw away my power did the same to my
will
trapping him in an eternal status quo
from which there could be no release an
eternity of filling spreadsheets for
employees who solely existed in my head
of nine o'clock meetings with no one
faked masturbatory crushes over
imaginary woman an eternity of tired
grinding mediocrity but that was over at
night with your soul burning in the
atmosphere like the loneliest of stars I
awakened
I died or whatever left that little cell
turned apartment wasn't me anymore
I was never more than an earth one
distinct from all the rest and then I
had a little more control over the soil
in which I crawled they never thought me
more than a minor reality bender a
bundle of introverted powers and
neuroses that was very unlikely to ever
pose any serious threat and they were
right the person I was SCP 1915 as they
called me never was anything other than
that but 1915 died that day watching a
fallen star the thing that then swatted
the guards at itself like they were less
than ants but raised site 17 into this
fine white sand was so warm beneath the
feet there was something else not an
entity for that would imply a
personality and this thing surely has
none not a purpose but there was no
purpose behind its action then nor will
there be for any of its actions to come
nor was it a will for it once nothing
not vengeance not Dominion not freedom
not even simple power
no I had to describe that thing as
anything at all it would be in an
absence a void where the entity should
be a lack of purpose
an imbecile force devoid of all will an
absence sand is still worn to the feet
that means the Sun still burns by above
I wonder why it lets it remain when all
else was so quickly erased when it could
so easily just reach and pluck it out of
the sky
and have been another I suspect it was
to mock humanity's memory to mock that
sliver of me that still persists in the
flesh stubborn like a buried tick but
this is absence
it does not mock after sight Seventeen's
destruction retaliation soon followed
standard containment teams at first
though certainly still enough to meet
any anomaly the foundation imagined it
could be contained in site 17 with
overwhelming force
when those men failed to return failed
to even report their arrival more
serious measures had to be taken site 17
has always been isolated and so they can
act freely gunships and fire teams
aerial bombardment and artillery
barrages the foundation came down on
what it still believed to be a CP 1915
like a fire God's fist all heat and
sound and bluster
had it been still truly corporeal I
doubt even ashes would have remained but
whatever the absence truly was by that I
mean tattered semblance of my flesh
hanging around it had very little to do
with it it simply stood there and took
it all in and the Foundation's initial
fury was soon spent it then began to
walk and not too quickly over four days
it simply leisurely strode on while the
foundations through everything in had
added I watched from within my deadbolt
as it walked unfeeling uncaring and this
desert followed in its wake as
inscrutable and unstoppable as its
Harbinger
we are not quite alone here some
stubborn immortals persist wretched
creatures a continent away an ancient
man still walked tormented by three
mocking voices he believed that once he
was the only one left he would be
allowed to rest he was wrong
beneath the ground is a soul suffocating
as the earth slowly grinds its sanity to
mulch from its prison of gold and rubies
there would be no release elsewhere lies
a once smiling God as the sands cover
his prone figure he does not resist
it once promised the world his love
promised humanity the Stars sand paws
through his fingers as he tries to
gather his flame together his people but
it is dying and they are dead
extinguished when someone walks they are
bound to reach somewhere eventually
despite everyone's best efforts and so
the absence arrived at its first city
sands at its heels like an obedient
lapdog oh there have been villages and
towns before that but the absence didn't
seem to care enough to bother with them
it simply walked by be remembered to the
whims of sands which were only ever
singular in their intent but through the
streets of the city it strode as mobile
task forces fought and fell to by the
civilian population just a few more
minutes to evacuate by this point hiding
what was truly going on became
impossible of course as the street after
sank beneath that gentle crawling tide
the foundation had of course attempted
to evacuate the city once it realized
there would be no stopping the absence
but if I've learned anything in my yawns
as a corporate peon is that organizing
an operation of that magnitude is
something that takes a lot more time
than the Foundation had it's a one that
they managed to save as many as they did
as for the rest
I had waited until night film I imagine
was an eerie sight that lone figure
standing beneath the frozen light of
other worlds in that empty intersection
between financial and residential
districts my train tracks used to be
before the old steam locomotives went
out of service and were never replaced
by newer ones yes it waited until it
could see the Stars and it burned
without heat without light without life
it burned a hole through the city and
there was nothing to fill it in reality
cannot suffer a vacuum they always said
but the absence had shown how little it
cared for reality so it was gone
just like that
how does one explain something like that
how do you describe what isn't there
where one moment was a city of 500,000
the next it wasn't the place it was even
the sands wouldn't come it was just a
scar it was nothing it was then I
believe that the foundation realized it
could not stand alone the next few
months of the absences March saw them
turned to sometimes allies coalition
mage killers and thermo nuclear strikes
initiative paladins and holy relics
sniper rifle or sacred sword burning
inferno or divine retribution the
absence did not care and soon the
foundation had no allies left to turn to
it then called on its once vicious
enemies in Kita's who of their art and
maddening patterns to break the minds of
the Infinity archivists and librarians
poured from the ways bring with them the
knowledge 400,000 worlds clockwork
Titans shook the barren whiteness of the
sands with the thunder of metal the
absence did not care and soon the
foundation man out of enemy in a last
act of desperation they then committed
their final most painful betrayal
the wardens unleashed upon the world
they're prisoners of these I have made
note though I doubt the absence did the
same on the blasted wasteland that was
once Boston it was assailed by two
brothers one savage the other Zomba one
violent the other reluctant they
nevertheless fought with a graceful
unity to take the breath away in their
eyes I saw that they did not know each
other for a very long while and that
they fought so there they could have
time to rectify this
I saw regret and hope rage and
desperation but most of all I saw a
simple need to be I would like to
believe that you and I would have been
like them had we met brother they fought
with the fury of a thousand years of
Solitude it did not suffice
in a wounded Valley that had once been
part of the Black Sea we came across a
self-proclaimed God there was nothing
but confidence in his eyes as he threw
reality itself into disarray and then
twisted its most fundamental laws to
bring upon the absence untold
destruction the earth frozen boiled and
heaved there screamed with blighted Glee
and the God he strode draped in a cloak
of lightning as time itself clawed at
the absence with talons of utter unbe
until the God came to meet the absence
lack of a gaze until his eyes rested on
a nothing that lasted forever until he
did not suffice before the walls of Acre
as the ancient city was drowned by the
desert two figures approached us one was
four legged and hardened its crown was
ice its eyes galaxies its whole was
power absolute the second was a man
simple humble but possessing a lover
being that extended to the edges of the
universe compassion to pierce the
deepest of hell's that had nothing to do
with weakness of the two I cannot tell
you which was more glorious which was
more terrifying
they meant the absence with will alone
and when I felt it fall on us I thought
I would weep surely nothing could
withstand such a presence surely nothing
would want to but the absence was less
than nothing infinitely less I have told
you what became of kind Pangloss well
the other even less remained for months
they came for years for decades alone or
in groups with ferocity are with a blank
stare the Foundation's prisoners threw
themselves at the absence I could not
hope to imagine the reasons behind the
actions of every individual anomaly but
I could guess I would say that the idea
of sharing existence with a thing like
the absence
golde them to the point of madness I
don't blame them but by the end the
prisons ran empty as the world dried up
as life was drained from it inch by inch
grain by grain only one city remained I
do not know by which power I was allowed
to send my senses ahead of us as the
absence marched towards that tottering
bastion which held in its quivering
embrace the very last of humanity as the
sands around us buried the last of the
trees that will never grow in this land
I felt each tiny mode of life in that
sad place like the flame of a cheap
candle moments before the typhoon
in these moments as twilight danced in
lurid reds and oranges on ivory i sensed
them all for you brother
I witnessed in a low narrow room a woman
sat hunched at the foot of her even
narrower bunk and couldn't bring herself
to pray she had lost her mother when she
was but a babe
and though she was no longer young her
features still displayed to all the
violence of that incident her mother
stood before the eater of children and
did not budge and when they both fell
down she sang still the praise of her
Lord she lost her father in the first
days of the war against the absence as
the Paladins marched with holy fervor in
their eyes and father had been a
believer had always been a solid
presence in our life
an anchor a moveable by anything but
regret he had promised her he would be
back he did not mean to lie
but his God had forsaken him when it
counted most forsaken all of them and
now Naomi knelt at the foot of the ever
narrowing bunk and could not pray so she
cursed instead below in a series of dank
cellars which might have at one point
stored cheese's a woman of about forty
tinkered with broken toys when she was
young she made wonders such wonders in
every line edged across her prematurely
old face I saw it could have been had it
not been for the absence or me in the
dim light and the soft noise of rotting
wood crumbling beneath calloused fingers
I saw the death of potential the death
of all possibility
[Music]
though Isabelle was stubborn as she
always was she knew that this toy would
be her last just as well as she thought
after today there would be no one left
to play with it
on the rooftop of the highest building
still standing an elderly man watched
the world come to an end he was once an
agent of the foundation once among a
hundred thousand ready prepared and
collected his duty was to instructing
you agents what was proper for an agent
to do I was proper for an agent to think
and he had been very good at his job
since generally his recruits survived
long enough to thank him but what was he
now he wondered as he watched the sands
pour over the paltry last line of
defense that a few defiant fools erected
the day before his lads and lasses were
all long since dead and all that he knew
all of his years of training and
experience in the end they amounted to
less than nothing no longer an agent but
there was no longer an agency no longer
a teacher but the students were gone no
longer a man since well it would not do
to repeat that now wouldn't it
no longer anything and that was the
cruelest joke it no longer mattered if
the absence arrived he thought they were
already within it a noise behind him the
old man turned to see a small mousy man
in a wrinkled gray suit and a deflated
had that at one point was likely a
fedora he looked at the old man but said
nothing
Lombardi looked back and didn't know if
to laugh or cry soon it's easy to matter
such was the end quiet small bereft of
heroics and great deeds free of
pretensions of great meaning at one
night there was human race on the planet
Earth
the next there wasn't and that was that
the stars did not wait for you brother
when you took my power when you burned
yourself in the skies above they looked
upon you and felt nothing the stars did
not wait for humanity for all the
promise it showed for all the promise
that others saw in them but what are the
absent what of me
[Music]
we are I am by all accounts and possible
qualifications the greatest monster this
world has ever saw the ask that any
world saw and yet brother I see now that
the Stars wait for us for me where is
the justice in that seek it not for
there is an army
but the fact remains brother the stars
do not wait for you but they wait for me
to take them into my embrace I suspect
that I shall not be long
[Music]
you